this is a production of Cornell
University
great introduction to my talk but I'm
mounted in a little further
so let's stop start by talking about the
soil carbon cycle and how it is so
important to the global carbon site
so for those of you who aren't familiar
the soil carbon cycle starts in the
atmosphere is carbon dioxide plants
photosynthesize and fix that carbon into
their own biomass it becomes organic
carbon and then it ends up inevitably in
the soil in one form or another and from
there it can become stabilized in soil
for a long periods of time or it can be
emitted back out into the atmosphere
usually in the form of carbon dioxide
and this diagram that I'm showing here
doesn't do it proper justice but if you
look at those bottom number in the
corner there that's 2300 gigatons of
carbon in our soil that is three times
more than what's in the atmosphere and
four times more than what's in every
living body on the earth this is a huge
reservoir of carbon and as such there's
huge fluxes of carbon going into soil
and leaving soil
so what we're really concerned about in
terms of climate change is that because
of those huge fluxes there's huge
potential for feedbacks in this cycle to
climate change is the cycle going to
make our climate change situation worse
or maybe it'll mitigate it that's an
open question
and the key to understanding the cycle
and understanding these fluxes and how
they might change in the future is the
microbes
so microbes are key they decompose the
organic matter that ends up in the soil
and their metabolic metabolism
mineralizes it into forms that make it
back into the atmosphere
so the key the key issue here is we're
trying to model carbon and predicted in
the future
so let's talk a bit about that this
graph here is showing um the change in
total carbon stocks uh either increasing
or decreasing in the negatives and it
predicts that out using three models to
the year 2100 and we're looking at three
different models here and each model
makes different assumptions about how
the microbial Community works and how it
processes the carbon that it comes into
contact with one model is showing that
we're going to be building carbon stock
over time which sounds great another is
showing that there's going to be
negligible changes in our carbon stock
over time and last is showing
catastrophic losses in foil carbon and
this is a huge amount of variability to
have when we're trying to predict
something as important as by the climate
so
there's huge uncertainty in these models
and the real source of that uncertainty
is the microorganisms we need to study
these things so we that we can
parameterize them in our models in a way
that helps us predict what's going to
happen in the future
let's look into more detail about how
these microorganisms are processing the
carbon we see in our soils
so this is something we call the
microbial carbon pump and it's kind of
the working model that microbial
ecologists are using for microorganisms
in the carbon cycle
we start with Organic Matter shown here
as a dead decomposing leaf and the
carbon in that leaf is going to be
metabolized by the living microbial
biomass that exists in soil some of that
carbon is going towards making more
microbes more cells and some of that is
being lost in mineralization as carbon
dioxide
from there that living microbial biomass
is producing metabolic byproducts it's
also dying and becoming necromanced and
the key thing about these two pools is
that they're very sticky they tend to
become stabilized and soil via two
mechanisms one is called entombment
where that sticky stuff can kind of get
surrounded by soil particles within an
Aggregate and be separated from living
biomass that might otherwise eat it and
then it's stabilized and another major
mechanism is via adsorption so this
sticky microbial carbon can stick to the
outside of the soil Matrix usually via
mineral interactions and that makes it
inaccessible as well
so in this way microbes are driving
carbon losses but they're also driving
carbon stabilization so it's really
about the balance of these things that
matters
so we really want to know what
parameters are dictating
what pool carbon is going to end up in
in under what conditions
and if you think about it at it's very
like the very fundamental
uh at the very fundamentals but picking
problems growth and death are dictating
where the carbon is moving in these
pools
so that's why I focused on this for my
PhD work
so I'm going to give you an example of
how a growth
metric can inform carbon metabolism and
possibly carbon cycling in soils and to
do that we're going to talk about
something called carbon use efficiency
so this graph is showing on the y-axis
maximum growth rate and on the x-axis
that carbon use efficiency which is the
proportion of carbon used that ends up
as biomass and what this Landmark paper
found is that generally the faster a
microorganism grows the less efficient
it grows which means less of the carbon
it eats ends up as more cells and more
of it usually ends up as carbon dioxide
and other byproducts
so I'm going to make an analogy here
that I hope makes sense
we're going to pretend that
microorganisms are cars and that a fast
microorganism is like a sports car that
sports car can accelerate very quickly
and get from point A to point B very
fast but it's not being a very fuel
efficient while it does that whereas a
slower growing hybrid car microbe is not
going to get from point A to point B
quite as quickly but it's going to be
much more fuel efficient as it's doing
that so if we abstract this analogy out
to a microbial Community you can see how
maybe the community composition of a
microbial Community might matter in
terms of where carbon ends up if we have
a community filled with hybrid sports
car bacteria we might have uh more
carbon ending up stabilizing soil and
vice versa but
that remains to be proven
so
moving on
I wanted to go over how we do um
research and measure microbial
communities in soil for those of you who
aren't familiar
so the gist of it is that we take soil
from the plot or whatever area of
interest you extract all the DNA in that
soil and then we target a specific
marker Gene that is unique to each
species that occurs in the soil and this
particular gene is called a 16s V4
region of the ribosomal RNA Gene
um you don't need to remember that word
but that's what we use so then when we
uh we sequence that particular marker we
can assess the diversity in the soil
so we have a microbial community
each species in that microbial Community
has a unique sequence associated with it
and when we sequence those markers we
can kind of count them up and see okay
we have this many species here and
they're in these abundances in the soils
and this is great but it's actually not
good enough for estimating growth and
death
and there are two big reasons why the
first is this data is compositional
the second is how do we even estimate
something like growth and death in
really complex data so let's talk a
little bit more about those two things
so sequence data is fundamentally
compositional which not a lot of people
know but it is true and I have uh some
graphs here that are showing this how
this can affect things
um badly
so on the your left hand side we have
two species they're both growing at
different rates and I've shown that data
in two different ways when we sequence
it all it becomes compositional and that
creates strange artifacts and excuse the
abund the perceived abundances of these
species in the samples
so you can see that now growth looks
warped and it can even look like death
in some cases this is the same data but
it's compositional and I can't it'll be
really problematic to try to estimate
growth and depth from data like this
fortunately there is a fairly simple
solution and that is to use internal
standards in your sequencing efforts
so here we have an example of species a
it's this is B again one is growing the
other Remains the Same abundance
throughout two time points and two of
these uh samples we're going to add the
same amount of an internal standard uh
known DNA sequence that we can track
throughout the sequencing process
so when we sequence uh Things become
wonky including the internal standard
it's accounts have been biased to
reflect that compositionality but those
numbers still reflect the same amount of
DNA so we can use that to correct the
abundances of our own Known Unknown
species
and I did that you do that by basically
just dividing the internal standard
counts by each species counts and you
get something called a normalized
abundance
and at the end of that you get something
that looks like this so the actual
abundances aren't the same as what they
would be in the environment but the
relationships between those abundances
are corrected and that's what is really
important if I'm interested in growth
and death Dynamics
so great
we can bypass this compositionality
issue
so now I have a way to get the data I
need but next problem is how do we
estimate growth and death so this graph
is an example of one species from one of
my experiments and we have the log
normalized abundance on the y-axis and
time on the x-axis in first glance at
this you're like Cassie of course that's
growing look at it but that's not very
scientific
um we need a way to objectively say that
growth or death did occur
we need a way to say when that period of
growth or death happen because it's
pretty obvious looking at this that this
species didn't grow throughout the
entire period right
and then we also need to be able to do
that like hundreds of and that maybe
thousands of times because of how much
data we have
so so to tackle that problem I created
this algorithm that I'm calling an
elongating sliding window
and this algorithm detects all potential
periods of growth and depth and then
chooses the one best one
so I'm going to show you how this works
using a idealized example that I made up
so again we have normalized abundance on
the y-axis and day on the x-axis
and
what we're going to do is we're going to
take a linear regression and fit it to
every single possible time window in
this data and we're going to ask a
question is the slope of that regression
significantly different from zero if
it's greater than zero that indicates
growth if it's less than zero that
indicates that
so let's run through this
first the algorithm picks the minimal
set of time points from the beginning
and fits a linear regression
elongates it checks again elongates
checks again moves over checks again
elongates
Etc
so in this way it's going to check every
single possibility and record
um
what seems to possibly be growth or
death
and at the end in this example we end up
with two possibilities for growth and I
decided to pick the best one based on
the one with the lowest residuals or
errors surrounding that regression
so we end up with something that looks
like this and I just did a lot of
regressions so to control for false
positives I randomly generated data and
applied the same algorithm to it to
assess just how many serious uh growth
or death estimates would I get in data
that obviously isn't reflecting growth
and controlled for that
all right
so here's our example again this is what
my algorithm decided was probably the
best guess for when this was growing and
from this one regression we can actually
get quite a bit of information for
instance when start at the start and end
of growth were
we can get the growth rate based on the
slope of this regression
we can also get a indication of the net
growth of that organism
so the difference in the abundance at
the end of the time period versus the
beginning and it's important to note
that this isn't just growth it's growth
minus death because death can be
happening simultaneously as growth it's
just when growth exceeds death is when
it appears to be growing all right
so let's actually get into my
experiments now my main hypothesis for
all this work was that variation in
microbial growth Dynamics will drives
variation in soil carbon cycling
so
my first chapter I looked at how
different soils with differing carbon
fate might differ in their bacterial
growth Dynamics
in the second chapter I looked
specifically at how these growth metrics
shift over the course of decomposition
of plant litter
and in my third chapter I was trying to
combine Lessons Learned From the first
two and assess this
what bacterial growth strategies might
be existing in soils and what that means
for carbon cycling in those soils
and at the end we're going to talk a
little bit about how growth and death
are late
okay
on to the first chapter so here my
prediction is that soils with differing
carbon Fates are going to reflect that
with differences in their microbial
growth metrics that I can measure
and to test that I had an experimental
design that used soil microcosms I went
out into a field grab soils and put it
in a bottle
oh whoops
didn't mean to do that a slideshow from
current slide perfect no problem okay so
I took soil from an agricultural plot
which has more disturbance and there and
tends to have less carbon stored and
also a successional plot that hadn't
seen agricultural agriculture in a
really long time
and was less Disturbed and had more
carbon stored in its soil as a result
to the soil I added water
and or some
like a cocktail of carbon compounds for
the microbes to enjoy and eat and this
was a combination of soluble and
insolute soluble carbon compounds that
are commonly found in plant litter
the common constituents
I incubated these for 50 days and I took
samples and triplicate destructively
over time
and from there I did sequencing and my
growth estimations
so these are four examples of species
that I found in these soils just to kind
of showcase the diversity that we're
looking at here the uh again normalized
abundance on the y-axis I am on the day
axis
um and the dashed line is showing my
growth estimate from the algorithm the
inset numbers there
um are showing you g which stands for
Generation time and that is the number
of days that the population needs to
double in size so a lower generation
time means faster growth
lag is how long how many days it took
for that population to start growing
and then net growth is showing just the
difference in abundance at the beginning
and end
so that's what for my examples look like
but overall I got 453 species estimates
in this way
the average generation time was five
days but it ranged from less than a day
to over 60 days
the lag time was on average one and a
half days but ranged from zero to all
the way to 21 days and then the net
growth varied by four orders of
magnitude so we're looking at a broad
range of diversity here
in terms of their growth strategies
and then I looked at these growth
metrics in two different ways kind of a
broad level resolution and a really fine
resolution so I have three replicates
and one way to look at this is to take
my growth metric like growth rate and
just average it for every single growing
member in that sample which I called a
community level metric
the other way to do it oh and you do
that for every Rebel kid obviously
the other way to do it is to look at it
this information species by species so
instead averaging across replicates for
an individual species and doing that for
each species that group
so let's look at the community level
data so this graph is showing the prompt
and successional soils and the closed
circles are where samples where I added
water plus carbon to eat and the Open
Circles are just water
so this lag time so how long it took
these organisms to start growing uh was
significantly affected by both land use
and carbon addition so it took microbes
longer to start growing if they were
from the successional soil
and also if they didn't get carbon added
to them which kind of makes sense
I also looked at net growth so how much
they grew and uh unsurprisingly when you
add carbon to a microbial community and
give them more food they grow more so
that's encouraging to see but I didn't
see any effect of land use on this
but then when we looked at growth rate
it's data's all over the place and I
don't see any effects and that's
confusing but I didn't give up here I
decided to look at species level what
this data looked like and so to explain
this graph
on the x-axis we have the growth rates
and on the y-axis we have something
called kernel density which is a fancy
way of showing frequency so if something
has a higher Peak it means there's more
individuals growing at that growth rate
than something with a lower Peak
all right and then this data is showing
the water treatment
and what you can see first see here is
that these are not normal distributions
and these distributions look and are
different from one another between soils
and also something that stuck out to us
was that there seems to be two
subpopulations Within These
distributions a slower group and a
faster growth group
when we look at the carbon added data
these distributions seem to shift
and look more similar to one another
but it does seem like there's still
different groups within the whole
community
so to look at this um in more
statistically I use something called
gaussian mixture modeling which is a way
to test if a distribution is best fit by
multiple normal distributions
and I found that in most of my
treatments shown here that the
distributions were best described by two
normal distributions rather than just
one with the cropped water added being
the odd one out
but using these clusters I could then
say see that the slower group
tended to shift upward in growth rate
when carbon was added but the faster
group didn't
so this is interesting we have shown
that different groups of bacteria can
respond differently in their growth
metrics when we give them food
additionally we wouldn't have known that
if we just looked at the community in
aggregate it's this shows the value of
looking at
individuals within a community instead
of just looking at the broad Strokes
but that's all alone good what does that
mean for carbon cycling you ask well let
me tell you all right so we're on to
chapter two and here I'm looking at how
these growth metrics are changing over
the decomposition process
so my prediction is that growth traits
will vary during decomposition
reflecting different stages of
decomposition
and I have a similar experimental design
but one key difference is that I use
sand microcosms that I inoculated a soil
microbial Community onto and fed some
grass material and the reason I did this
was because I wanted to remove the
influence of soil carbon and other
compounding factors so I just focus on
the decomposition
I incubated these took growth estimates
and took also CO2 measurements so I can
get an idea of what the carbon flux was
like
okay
so one thing I noticed when looking at
this data is that the entire community
so we're looking at the total abundances
of the communities I tested over time
they go through very distinct phases so
there's something called an exponential
phase or growth exceeding death
and then the communities transition into
what's called a stationary phase where
growth is equivalent to death
and what's interesting about this is
that CO2 emissions from these
communities tend to be increasing during
this phase and decreasing during this
phase at least in the experiment this
experiment that I ran
so I wondered is there a difference
between microorganisms that only grew
during this early phase versus ones that
continued growing throughout
which I called early and continuous
respectively
so here's two examples of those so these
are individual species and you can see
that this early example abruptly can't
continue growth as it was when it hits
that um Community Plateau whereas this
other species just kept on going
so I I looked at the growth metrics for
these two groups
um and I found that growth rates and net
growth were different for these groups
so the early Growers tended to have
higher growth rates than the continuous
Growers but despite that the early
Growers didn't grow as much as the
continuous Growers
and so I wanted to know
how do these different strategies relate
to carbon cycling in these microcosms
to do that I calculated something that
I'm calling a net growth efficiency
which is the sum of all of the
microorganisms that grew the change in
their abundance during a certain time
period divided by the amount of
mineralized carbon dioxide so what this
means is that if a community grew very
little in a time frame but emitted a lot
of carbon dioxide we'd consider that
lower efficiency whereas if a community
grew very little but also emitted very
little carbon dioxide we need to
consider that higher efficiency
because less we're losing less carbon
for the same amount of growth
all right
so this is what that data looks like
over time
we see an increase in the growth
efficiencies and then a plateau at
around day 12. and then this is where
um that shift from early to continuous
growth started to happen so it seems
like there might be a relationship
between these growth traits and what's
happening to the carbon
and what I found was that when I looked
at the weighted mean growth rates of a
community so based on the abundance of
the species
um and compare that to the respiration
rate of a community at a given point in
time there was a strong positive
correlation so the respiration if a
community has on average greater growth
or faster growth I should say
it tended to be respiring more carbon
so the takeaway here is that they're
displaying towards a relationship
between the growth strategies that
exists in a community and the carbon
carbon cycling that's happening within
that community
but what about natural soils remember I
took sand put litter plant litter in it
and then inoculated a community on top
of that let's look at this stuff in an
actual soil which is what chapter three
is about
so my prediction here is that
differences uh for in soils that have
different carbon carbon fate there will
be differences in the growth strategies
represented
so I have a very similar experimental
design I'm back to using actual soil and
my macrocosms and I looked at an
agriculture agricult agricultural versus
a meadow soil which have low and high
carbon storage respectively
and on top of this information oh and I
added bent root as their food source
on top of this information I added some
data that a previous grad student had
collected from these same soils so he
looked at what these species tended to
like to eat in terms of their carbon
sources and so this gives me an idea of
what their carbon metabolism might be
like
I'm going to use those to assess what
life history strategies exist Within
These communities because there's I'm
expecting there to be combinations of
these
traits or metrics
let's take a detour and talk about life
history strategies so for those of you
who aren't familiar this is very well
studied in plants and it turns out that
this uh theory that I'm going to talk
about is actually pre-use bacteria so
bear with me this is called the CSR
triangle Theory it was made up by Grime
in the 1970s and it's actually pretty
useful for plants
so we have plants that are considered
competitors like a tree and they tend to
have moderate growth rates and they have
a lot of traits for resource acquisition
like making a lot of uh limbs that can
capture as many uh as much sunlight as
possible
we have stress tolerators like a cactus
and those tend to have really slow
growth rates and a lot of traits for
survival
we have root rules which are weeds these
have fast growth rates got a lot of
traits geared towards Rapid reproduction
and all of these traits are results of
the environments that these species
grew up in
so a tree became a tree because it was
an environment where competition was a
big selective Force
a weed became a weed because it evolved
in areas with a lot of disturbances like
wildfires the faster you're able to
reestablish the better off you're going
to be
and then a you know a cactus is a cactus
because it's in the desert there's not a
lot of resources available and there's a
lot of stress to deal with
so all of these traits trade off to
create an Optimum life history strategy
for where it is in the world
and as it turns out this is actually
pretty useful for understanding life
history strategies and bacteria that
grad student that I talked about earlier
looked at various uh carbon metabolism
traits
Etc and found that they map pretty well
to this framework so this competitor and
ruderal and
stress tolerator uh lifestyle not going
to go into detail here but um yeah it
looks vaguely triangular and the traits
make sense
so my question is will this hold up with
the growth metrics that I'm measuring
so what I did was I took these features
I took growth rates lag times
um growth length and net growth as the
features I measured and then I
Incorporated a carbon carbon metabolism
features like is that species able to
use xylose or cellulose
and I fed this into an algorithm called
Camilla which is an implementation of
the k-means algorithm that can handle
mixed type data which is what this is
so I went from this
blob of data to something that I could
start parsing out and looking at
groupings of traits or metrics Within
so let's look at those it to my surprise
it actually works out so in this uh
purple cluster that I found
there were a lot of uh there was a lot
of information that pointed towards a
competitor life like lifestyle and
for the other clusters
it worked out as well I've changed
stress tolerator to scarcity adapted
because when we're thinking about
bacteria
in terms of the carbon metabolism the
stress that we're thinking about is
actually lack of resources
but to sum up the differences between
the strategies and these different
clouds of data
we've got
um rude roles with really high growth
rates and competitors and scarcely
adapted bacteria with lower slower
growth rates
we've got net growth being very high for
the root rules and competitors so when
they grew they grew a lot
and growth being very low for these
scarcity adapted ones
and then spanning kind of up and down
we have
substrate use profile
so these competitor type bacteria tended
to use a great diversity of different
substrates and didn't really have a
preference for any single one whereas
the scarcity adapted microbes
tended to be kind of picky with what
substrates they wanted to use and really
prefer to use amino acids
and the gruderals kind of spanned both
had a lot of variation in whether it was
picky or you know eight more things and
didn't prefer anything in particular
all right
first thing I asked was how do these
strategies differ between these soils so
I looked at the total abundances of each
cluster in each soil and I found that
while the scarcity adapted cluster
tended to be pretty equivalently
represented in the Agricultural and
metal soils I found that the competitor
and ruderal clusters were much more
elevated in the meadow soil and that the
ratio of those the competitor and Rural
clusters was different between those
soils so they're pretty much equivalent
in agriculture but there's much more
competitive life history strategy than
rude role in the meadow
on top of that if we look at the net
growth of each individual in those
clusters in the metal soil the
competitor and riteral strategies tended
to grow more in response to the carbon
that I added in the meadow soil compared
to the AG soil but less so for the
scarcity adapted
so it looks like these competitor and
rural
like strategies are particularly
important to understand the differences
between these soils
so the question is can I use this
information to make sense of the carbon
cycling that's happening in these soils
so we're going to go over a few facts
and
the first is that these agriculture the
Agricultural and the meadow soils differ
in their abundances of these two groups
overall
we also know that these two groups
differ most in their growth rates
competitors are slower
router rolls are faster
and we know that between the two
different soils the net growth of those
cluster or those strategies differ
so I have all this information to work
with in terms of under the Standard
carbon cycle and it's a lot of moving
Parts I'm getting confused and my big
brain idea is just to smush it all
together in one number and see if it's
explanatory so I'm calling this a
crammed parameter I am taking name
suggestions uh but I think it's
descriptive enough so I've taken the
weighted mean So based on the abundance
of that of a species in its community so
this is kind of capturing that Community
composition aspect and the way to mean
the ratio of the growth rate to the net
growth because those are the sources of
variation I think matter for these two
different clusters
okay so I calculated net growth
efficiency in these soils you see it
increases plateaus and then decreases
but that the metal soil overall has a
higher growth efficiency than the AG
soil
when I looked at my cramped parameter
um the AGS will had a much higher
level of this parameter than the meadow
soil and when I look at this inter
compare these in terms of net growth
like comparing the net growth efficiency
to the crammed parameter there seems to
be a negative correlation
and it's useful for predicting the
differences in efficiency between soils
but less so over time because each of
these dots is basically a Time Point
um and you can see that kind of differs
between soils but maybe we're onto
something
so the take home here is that it's not
just about the growth rates in a
community but also how much growth
happens and the community composition of
the strategies that exist
and we're interested in finding
parameters like these because we're
really if we're thinking about the first
half of that microbial carbon pump we're
interested in knowing how much carbon
ends up in living microbial biomass
versus being emitted as carbon dioxide
and loss so maybe using leveraging
information from life history strategies
can help us find modeling parameters
that help
so finally we're going to talk about
growth and death
so
yes I was taking death measurements this
entire time but I withheld them until
now so I found throughout all of my
experiments that there was a very strong
correlation between net growth and net
death so that means if something grew
more it also died more if you you grow
more you have more to lose
um and you can see that this was true in
my communities on sand microcosms in
both the AG and Meadow soils
and then I also found it from chapter
one where I added differing amounts of
carbon that this relationship was
strengthened if you gave the micro
microbial Community more food
so
this is relevant this sounds kind of
obvious but it's relevant because if
we're thinking about the back half of
the microbial carbon pump
it's the necromass that matters because
that's the sticky stuff that can become
stabilized in the soil so if we can
predict that more death is going to be
happen as a result of more growth maybe
that can help us understand how carbon
stocks might change over time
so yeah to wrap up I'm gonna do a quick
summary so from chapter one I found that
land use impacts different groups with
differing growth rates differently when
I add carbon
so there's some Nuance there when we're
thinking about strategies and soils
in chapter two where I looked at growth
traits in terms of decomposition I found
that faster growth rates were associated
with lower efficiencies and higher
respiration
in chapter three I found evidence for
CSR like strategies in the soils and I
found that C's into ours the competitors
and root rules were kind of the most
explanatory for what was going on in
terms of the community composition and
carbon cycling in these soils
and finally I found that more growth led
to more death
and that is the end of my presentation
thank you for listening
highly recommend putting your
experiments on wheels
you briefly describe your assay for
death
oh oh it's a good calculation or is it
are you actually measuring it's exactly
the same as the growth one but I'm just
looking for zero slopes so do you think
you could actually measure neck changes
in necromass in the soils okay so I mean
there's an easy extraction yeah
um
are you talking about in terms of the
algorithm I made or using okay
we have net growth yep
it would actually have the road
measurement and you can quantify how
many cells die
right so I think the way I've heard of
this being done is
um you using Mass Spectrum
spectrometry to see if a carbon compound
looks like it has microbial features
right so that's the way I would go about
doing it
um and I'm pretty sure like
we don't have that compositionality
problem with that data so more of this
type of compound would correspond to an
actual increase in death I think one of
the complications in soils is that the
amount of biomass and necromass is
already so high that when you give it
carbon the perturbation is so slight
that you need an awful lot of power to
see it so that can be become complicated
um it might be easier to do in a setup
where like you're removing the soil from
the equation and all of its
heterogeneity uh maybe that's a place to
start but yeah I was wondering the sand
cultures oh yeah I have no carbon to
start with well you add um plant litter
but using mass back you should be able
to tell that from what becomes necromass
so so definitely
yes
good question so um I realized for
people who want who are on Zoom uh they
might not be able to hear these
questions the question is what is the
difference between carbon use efficiency
and the growth efficiency and they are
not the same because I am not actually
measuring carbon I'm using the sequence
data I'm just looking at a change in
abundance I don't know how much carbon
was used by these microbes and I don't
know how much actual carbon went into
that biomass
so it's kind of a proc it's a little bit
of a proxy for carbon use efficiency but
not exactly analogous because in order
to actually get a carbon use efficiency
measure you need to know how much carbon
was used how much became biomass or how
much was lost so that's the main
difference
uh I think yeah let me check that
okay oh Jenny asks
um could you speak to some of the uh
speak about some of the barriers of the
researchers might face when using
internal standards how can we as a
community make this easier to adopt good
question so I think internal standards
would be great for everyone to start
using but it wasn't exactly super easy
to implement in my experiments
um there's a very fine window of I added
way too much internal standard and now
most of my sequences are internal
standard and I didn't add enough
traditional standard and now I have none
to use in my experiment so I had to do
sequencing multiple times in some cases
to get that uh quantity correct and also
I couldn't really predict it either
because there's so much heterogeneity
heterogeneity and variability in these
various like how much DNA is in the soil
and how much of it is fungal versus
bacterial DNA that that becomes an issue
I think it would be really helpful for
more microbial ecologists to
start making more standardized
procedures for this stuff the internal
standard I use built on work that had
been already done and verified by other
scientists but we could definitely use a
lot more and I know there are
um like uh that zymo they are selling
internal standards for scientists to use
as well but there's still the issue that
there's a lot of nuance when it comes to
making it work for your particular
project
so hopefully that answers your questions
enemy
and Kirsten I saw you raise your hand
and if you wanted to unmute you could
ask hello
that was so interesting
um you have really intriguing outcomes
in terms of the time frame and you know
I was just talking to my postdoc about
this the other day in interpreting some
of the isotope results
often they're short incubations and what
you showed is like from zero to ten days
which maybe is the time frame that many
people do like incubation experiments
you find really different results than
in the later time frame and so I was
curious about the implications of your
research for inferring from like lab to
field or even when we sample on like
shorter time frames on the field because
what you're showing is there may be
these like more like instantaneous or
short-term responses that that are
really the fast Growers and we're not
capturing sort of the more holistic
metabolism of the community so I was
just curious about your thoughts on like
the broader implications of your
findings yeah so you're right that most
um growth studies right now in situ are
pretty short and that's obviously by
biasing things towards those like
ruderals and maybe faster growing
competitors
um things that like don't start growing
until like day 20 are going to be
completely missed but that doesn't mean
they're not important especially when
carbon cycling is something that happens
over the course of years and you know I
only measured things for 30 days but it
just goes to show how much diversity you
can even miss in that short time frame
so I think the more we can start pushing
these experiments out the more insight
we're going to get into
how microbial communities affect carbon
cycling but did that kind of answer your
question
it did yeah and I'm also thinking about
like in the field how that impacts like
temporal sampling right because you've
also got like those in the lab we're
often controlling those carbon inputs
but in the field they're sort of like a
plant phenology that's going to
influence those fast and slow Growers so
yeah I think it does it's an interesting
um challenge for like that time part is
an interesting challenge we always talk
about heterogeneity and complexity I
feel like that time part often doesn't
get as much and your research really is
is poignant in that in that front
right so yeah I wouldn't even attempt to
do this in a field because of the
heterogeneity I just I probably wouldn't
get any estimates but um
yeah
I I think
right now I would only attempt this
experiment under very controlled uh like
because I showed you some nice examples
of growth but there was a lot of
variation as well because there's
stochasticity that's going on and
all kinds of other issues so that's
definitely a very important thing to
think about but thanks
yeah great talk thank you I saw a
Vanessa raise your hand
yep so Kirsten actually prompted a
question that was going through my head
during your talk and so I kind of want
to just probe this a little bit there's
an old hypothesis that I think has held
up for a really long time and that's
that when we're looking specifically at
how substrates are are modified by
microbes into durable soil carbon the
hypothesis has been that the more
rapidly decomposed substrate so that
faster flush of carbon dioxide those
substrates are associated with more
carbon persisting in the soil longer
term
and it's it was always a little bit
counter-intuitive but it's something
that's held up for a really long time
and just thinking about what you put up
that was focused on the microbes and
their responses I was wondering if you
can kind of comment on on what the
mechanism there could be and and how you
might test it going forward yeah uh the
first thing that comes to my mind is
death if there's a lot of growth
happening um and we don't measure this
but there's probably a lot of death that
happens after that and that's the stuff
that tends to get stabilized right so
maybe if we do something like Joe was
saying and uh measure mass spec how much
necromass is the result of a fast carbon
decomposition and we see that there's
like an increase that might help explain
why that carbon can be more persistent
in the long run
so awesome that's interesting it's
something I've always wanted to explore
more deeply with with mechanistic
understanding rather than just
correlations so thanks very much really
nice presentation
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu